i value truth but i also look at results
the reality is
that trump didn't cleanse the swamp he
filled it didn't he
you're entitled to your opinion but
you're not entitled to your facts
he needs more than his base to win the
election it comes down to getting out
the vote
as the u.s election campaign draws to a
close most of the polls show joe biden
in front
but the trump campaign still insists the
president can
and will win a second term my guest this
week from austin texas
is mika mossbacker a former co-chair of
the republican national committee
and now adviser to the trump campaign if
it's all going so well
why has mr trump himself started talking
about losing
[Music]
mika mosbacher welcome to conflict zone
we've seen a steady stream of prominent
republicans jumping
ship to vote for joe biden and now
donald trump himself talks publicly
about
losing if i lose he said i'll have lost
to the worst candidate in the history of
presidential politics
he's already talked about how tough it's
going to be to hold on to the senate
what hope is there for your campaign if
trump himself
is already behaving like a loser well i
don't think he is he's a fighter and
he's continuing to fight for the
american people
certainly is out working and
outperforming uh
biden for example with three plus
rallies a day sometimes speaking 80
minutes at a time
in nebraska for example this past week
25 000 people
he's been in florida thousands of people
are turning out to
hear the president's messaging you
referred to the uh
democrats and sorry refer to the
republicans
um that have jumped ship i presume
you're talking about the lincoln project
for example
which uh it's found with rick wilson is
a moderate
and did work for president bush as well
as the co-founder john weaver who worked
for kasich
well not just them not just them there
are plenty of people and he's been
attacked in the last few days of the
campaign hasn't he by senior members
of his party that just doesn't happen in
the united party does it and certainly
not among the democrats
so your party's in a mess isn't it
well first of all so are the democrats
but secondly let me answer your question
um there are a number of republicans
that are establishment republicans and
they are not voting their values for
example because
republican values are smaller government
fewer regulations
pro-life so in a way that kind of
betrayed the party
secondly i was establishment my husband
served as secretary of commerce under
bush 41
and i did some soul-searching in 2016
and i looked at the field of contenders
including jeb bush and i realized
that an establishment candidate could
not win in this country
we were looking for a disrupter a person
that would throw a hand grenade into the
swamp and it came down to senator ted
cruz my
senator from texas as well as is uh
yeah i underst i understand that but
he's even having republican senators
turning on him
in the last few days of the campaign
harshest criticism came from
republican senator ben sasse he told
constituents trump mistreats women
flirts with white supremacy and secretly
mocks evangelicals again a pretty
damning indictment from your party just
before the election isn't it
that's just one senator most of them
what about john cornyn
your own son one of your own senators in
texas he said trump led his guard down
and got out over his skis as he put it
by playing down the threat from the
virus and he added
i think the biggest mistake people make
in public life
is not telling the truth and with that
he put his finger on one of the key
failings of donald trump didn't he the
truth
deficit now in the past you've tried to
finesse trump's lies by
calling them truthful hyperbole why
don't you call out lies when you hear
them
no principles no red lines for you
there are two warring ideologies in this
country
uh one is the country under
our traditional gop values of capitalism
as well as as i said before energy
independence small
talk about truth mika mossbacher i'm
talking about truth don't you value
truth anymore
i value truth but i also
look at results and trump has a
tremendous record
and resume to run on and this come on to
his record i'll come on to his record
but by defending his constant
distortions
you become part of the lying machine
yourself don't you
you do as much damage as trump because
you try to pretend that truth in
politics doesn't matter
is that how you want to be remembered
that is all hat and no cattle sort of
argument every single politician
flip-flops so if you want to talk about
an individual who's lying
look at the cover-ups this week in terms
of joe biden and his son
hunter and and his overseas business
dealings for example we don't know
anything about these overseas business
dealings and
nor do you and nor do you so this is
just a smear isn't it
nothing has been proven one way or the
other proven
it hasn't been answered but there is a
laptop and there are emails
and these questions will not be resolved
prior to the election
that's absolutely true but what you're
talking about
are flip-flops i'm talking about
i'm talking about false and misleading
statements
twenty thousand of which president trump
has made since he took office according
to the washington post
the trouble is mika mossbacker that
trump's lies have victims especially
during this pandemic don't they
he's constantly played it down and
assured americans the virus was under
control
when he knew it wasn't he did this again
two days ago when he said
we're rounding the corner beautifully
simply not true is it complete nonsense
can you go along with this host like so
many of the mainstream
uh news organizations is is
propagandist machine for the democratic
party one
two we are hopeful
in this country because of operation
warp speed
uh a program that is developing
therapeutics like from desevere
and and in addition to uh accelerating
vaccine production in this country
trump is severe has been has been
labeled by the world health organization
as having no effect
on on the pandemic no effect
was less than transparent as was china
i have to say that no one
in the democratic party in my opinion
would have had a better response to this
virus
then uh donald trump first of all
i don't know how you can say that
because you know you have
a record 500 000 new cases
of covid in the past week 39
increase in the last 14 days infections
and hospitalizations
surging nationwide and the largest
increase is in hospital admissions
in your state texas which reported
almost a thousand new cases on tuesday
up 20 percent from a week ago and trump
tells the nation we're rounding the
corner beautifully and that
is nonsense isn't it it's not a
flip-flop it's just nonsense
no it's not first of all there is a
spike
absolutely but i just heard on cnn today
that the hospitalizations are declining
secondly mortality rate has declined 80
percent
so we certainly are beginning to round
the corner in the sense that we
understand this virus much more than we
did before
we understand how to mitigate it we can
target
uh certain areas such as el paso is
referred to
that are going to shut down temporarily
for two weeks but we're not going to
lock down our country such as germany
and france are doing
that kills the economy and there's also
collateral damage when you begin to
uh ignore the fact that individuals need
to go to work pay their mortgage
pay their rent feed their families um
there's
uh an issue here that people need that
optimism to get back to work and trump
built a robust economy before he will
build it again
people need the truth mika mossbacker
especially at a time of
a national health emergency
international health emergency
and anyway his precious stock market
doesn't believe him either does he
the dow jones index lost 1800 points
in three days he always prides himself
on the strength of the stock market
and he always says he's done a great job
but americans don't agree do they
he's done a great job we just got
fantastic news
that we have 33 record growth in this
country we haven't seen that kind of
figure since 1947.
markets don't like uncertainty and there
is uncertainty as we're going into this
election
the margins are razor thin so obviously
the market is going to respond to that
uncertainty to a degree it did in 2016.
but again americans are looking for
hope and they are in in contrast the
democrats who are running on the covet
virus
because they don't have any other
achievements to
uh highlight at this point you say
they're looking
you say americans you say americans are
looking for hope on
october the 8th the reuters ipsos poll
said 59
disapproved of trump's handling of the
virus only 37 percent
approved an overwhelming plurality of
americans do not believe him and do not
think he's handling it
correctly and you've got more than 227
thousand americans dead
you have four percent of the world's
population and more than
20 percent of the global death toll if
that's a great job
i'd wonder i'd really wonder what you
think would be a bad job
first of all i don't look at polls polls
were wrong in 2016 they predicted that
hillary clinton would win
so i don't pay attention to polls
secondly i'm not going to minimize the
number of individuals who've lost their
lives to this virus in this country
however as i said it would be nice if
someone in your party mentioned that
wouldn't it
we have an 80 decline in mortality rates
in this country
and that does represent hope we
americans need to get back to work
mothers need their children
in school the democrats that they had
their way
would push another lock down in this
country
i think that individuals are behaving
responsibly
they're listening to the cdc guidelines
they're
wearing masks the administration left
that up to individual states and
individual governors and individual
mayors
i live in texas we have a mass mandate
and individuals wear masks anytime they
enter a business or a restaurant
so the vice president has not been
following cdc guidelines he shouldn't
have been
having been exposed to someone who had
the virus or
let's say what five people in his group
who've now
contracted the virus he's still going
around he doesn't always wear a mask
does he
well first of all he's not like a
regular average citizen he's covered
tested
every single day individuals who are
meeting with him for example the oval
office were covered tested
individuals around him were wearing
masks so
so he's he's not your average he's
exploded in covid cases
he has worn masks in situations
where it was appropriate or required
such as touring
a plant general motors plant michigan
for example
um the white house since they have had
this outbreak with this virus has
certainly
uh in uh has even more stringent
uh requirements now more and more
individuals are wearing masking meetings
and vice president pence wears a mask
socially distancing
uh takes it off only when he's speaking
the president when he's speaking to
rallies is a football field away
practically from his supporters
so i think that the uh behaving very
responsibly mask in this country become
almost political at times i feel that
biden is wearing a mask just as a prop
uh he's on stage 10 feet away from an
individual
and and he's now got double mask on so i
i i i so so mock him for wearing a mask
now
i want to i want to get on to to trump's
record because one of his
most frequent promises has been to
cleanse
the swamp in washington the reality is
that trump didn't cleanse the swamp
he filled it didn't he if you look at
his former close associates and
appointees
who face criminal indictments many for
doing what their boss does every day
which is distorting
roger stone guilty of lying to congress
michael cohen former personal
lawyer guilty on eight criminal counts
george papadopoulos former foreign
policy adviser
guilty to lying about contacts with
russians paul manafort
michael flynn no he wasn't cleansing the
swamp trump has refilled it
with sleaze and criminals hasn't he no
absolutely not i mean and each
individual
uh for example flynn um that is not all
said and done
that's still an ongoing case so uh
we can't charge him as guilty
until that's been resolved paul manafort
was hired for one purpose only
he was hired to help with the delegates
in 2016
in in cleveland he was hired because of
his record
he wasn't there that long he was in and
out mike
says he's been so unfairly treated you
know
the irony is this is a man who kept
calling for hillary clinton to be locked
up
but it's his own people who've been
locked up and his own people who've left
under an ethical cloud in the from the
white house
well paul manafort wasn't in the
administration
michael cohen wasn't in the
administration okay well look at former
labor secretary alexander acosta
resigned after reports he was involved
in a plea deal for jeffrey epstein
ryan zinker multiple ethics
investigations he was former secretary
of the interior
david shulkin former veterans secretary
court sightseeing on government business
tom price health and human services
resigned after a scandal over his use of
private planes
what a collection in your swamp what a
collection in the swamp
that trump created isn't it well
look at the list the facts speak for
themselves mika mosbacher
yeah you're entitled to your opinion but
you're not entitled to your facts
because there are a number of
individuals
that are highly ethical uh that are
in this administration that are doing a
great job
and that are above reproach
be it our u.s secretary of treasury
stephen mentioned
being our commerce secretary be it
other individuals like betsy devos that
are in the cabinet
that that are are upstanding people
every single administration
has had some share of scandals
this is a lot this is a lot and
particularly scandal scandals
surrounding the president you have a
president who even misused
the finances of his own foundation used
as a personal checkbook
last year he was ordered to pay two
million dollars in damages
to charity for misuse of his
foundation's money
pretty sleazy behavior for the president
of the united states isn't it
tim his face is sticking with him
and we're in the middle we're a few days
you don't comment on this you
do do you not believe this is pretty
sleazy behavior
to misuse the funds of your own
foundation no
you just crush over it as if it's
nothing
i'm not getting into the weeds with that
the people are going to i know it's not
something you want to talk about but
it's a fact
he had to pay 2 million in damages
he called it a hoax but his lawyers had
to admit that he had misused his funds
in court the people are going to decide
this election
and we have equal scandals on the side
of buying
some cover-ups also things that have not
also come totally out in terms of his
son's business dealings overseas
so first of all i'm throwing that out i
am focused on this election
and who i feel can win and i believe
that president trump's base is sticking
with him
i know that it comes down to getting out
the vote which is why he's barnstorming
at these rallies this week
he is we have uh momentum and enthusiasm
on our side we have the largest ground
game in the history the republican
national committee and i've been
involved with them for years
we have 2.5 million volunteers we made
150 million
voter contacts i know he needs more than
his base though doesn't he he needs
more than his base to win the election
and he's reached
and you don't win it by setting example
of ripping off your own foundation do
you
americans who are voting for trump could
care
less okay we couldn't care less about
laws
or rules is that what you're telling me
you represent the lawless in america is
this what you're telling me
i represent a president that the people
elected barron square who i believe will
serve
a second term in this country who
represent policies that are my values
platform of smaller government energy
independence
um the fact that we don't have to rely
overseas
the fact that he's slap china with
tariffs the fact that he is
able to have this incredible middle east
uh
agreement between israel and the uh
united arab emirates which is something
that has been completely glossed over by
the media
he has done so many things in terms of
building the economy record unemployment
for latinos
for blacks and women he's done more for
blacks
speaking of independence he's done more
for blacks who are many walking away
from the
democratic party because they feel that
with his criminal justice reform first
step program and also the fact that
he has created economic opportunity
zones for individuals to have
capital for small businesses that means
something to the black population it
means something to latinos there's 31
million latinos
um who who vote who are eligible to vote
and with trump's plan of reaching out to
latinos
in uh texas for example in arizona which
is a very important state
in florida i feel that those individuals
will come over to trump's side because
at the end of the day people care about
kitchen table issues
they do not care about michael cohen who
is not
in the administration paul manafort
who's not in the administration
they care about results and they care
about their personal security
and how that's going to affect them
michael mossmeyer let's talk about women
for trump your your group
that you're associated with after all
the ways in which trump has
publicly insulted and demeaned women for
so many years
why why should any woman lift a finger
for him look at the insults rosie
look at the insults that he's he's
leveled against them rosie o'donnell
she's a slob how does she even get on
television if i were running her program
i'd fire rosie i'd look her right in
that fat ugly face of hers
and say rosie you're fired if he
referred to you
as a fat ugly slob would you work for
him
i've known him for years and i do work
for him the women that i know he's been
highly respectful
of and he was highly respectful of women
in the trump
organization in terms of also giving
them opportunities that they wouldn't
have elsewhere
i will say this that some women don't
like his tweets
some women don't like his tone and their
communication style but at the end of
the day they are more interested in
voting their values voting for the
platform rather than voting for a
socialist
candidate one day i don't know who biden
is he's a moderate one day he's a trojan
horse for the
progressive side of his party the next
day he's a bernie sanders in
sheep clothing so so you say but across
nearly every group of women voters biden
holds a significant
polling advantage women voters favor
biden by 11 points
suburban women are endorsing biden by a
14
majority 14 margin which means of course
that when trump
goes to one of these rallies and sees
women there
he's left with please like me please
like me a request
that's a little bit pathetic isn't it
from a president please like me
i've done so much for you really they
don't think so
i i disagree one of the lowest figures
of unemployment free pandemic
was within women women care about border
security they don't want drugs
coming across the border for example
there they don't like
children being separated from their
relatives and nor do you
do you you didn't like that policy
either
some of those policies were very
heartbreaking but you've got to also
realize that many of the children that
came across the border came across with
coyotes which are independent
smugglers and it was very difficult to
reunite them with the
parents the so-called cages were the
where the children were kept to keep
them safe
were built under obama that's neither
here nor there they weren't people
with with all the children that have
been separated
by your administration were they
that was a heartbreaking situation that
i didn't necessarily agree with as a
mother
however what i do agree with is the fact
that we've already
managed to build 374 miles of wall
i live in texas i want my border safe
i don't want the majority of drugs
coming in across my
border uh and into into the streets
where they're selling drugs and there is
crime and violence
i also care about police and president
trump is a law and order president he's
got the men and women in blue
he's got their back and that's important
to me
that's important to women and to
families i don't want to call 9-1-1
which is the
united states emergency number and get a
recording because the police
have been defunded and they've been
defunded 150 million dollars for example
here in austin texas where i live
so police unions for example are now
supporting trump
not fighting and normally many break for
a democratic candidate
so president trump must be doing
something right let me first let me just
let me just go back to the large numbers
of people who used to stand for
republican
voters used to stand for republican
values the people we've seen
former national security personnel who
now
vote for biden have decided to leave the
trump campaign behind
how can your party afford to lose
people of honor people who have given a
lifetime of honorable service to the
government do you really want to lose
that
those people the way you have we haven't
lost them we've lost establishment
recovering republican so-called rhinos
who don't vote their values we haven't
lost those individuals they think you've
trashed they think trump has trashed the
values of the republican party
he has his results his results have been
staggering he's done more in 47
months than biden's done in 47 years
again foreign policies
less dependency on china holding china
accountable for
intellectual property theft for example
um and telling xi jinping it's okay to
lock up a million wiegers he said that
wasn't a bad thing to do that's great
he's also held our allies
in nato accountable so that no longer is
america the world's piggy bank
23 out of 28 of our allies were not
paying their fair share of the 2 percent
standard so he's held them accountable
again
these policy decisions are
what make our party strong and at the
end of the day
individuals are going to vote for policy
and platform and republican
values we're running out of time we have
to leave it there thank you very much
for being with us thank you
[Music]
you